when sorted by oldest this image from
july 1st 2013 comes up first
okay that is funny
[Music]
we've quantified your digital footprint
so that you can see the impact you've
had
on the internet
[Music]
i want to see these i want to see them
this is what happens when you google
caleb mclaughlin
that's really interesting i see my face
see wikipedia
about 4530 000
results wow that's pretty awesome you
know i appreciate
it one section that comes up is people
also ask can you answer these questions
yes
i will is caleb mclaughlin in the lion
king
i'm not in the lion king animation but i
was in lion king on broadway for two
years from 2012 to 2014. so that is a
great question
i played young simba two years it was a
lot of fun
is caleb mclaughlin left-handed yes i am
i'm actually using my right hand right
now but i
am left-handed you know i actually when
i play basketball i dribble with my
right hand
and then i shoot with my left so i'm
it's it's interesting
you know i trick people a lot is caleb
mclaughlin single
yes i am um yeah i'm chilling right now
so
yeah you know what's funny if i'm
actually dating someone if i'm in a
relationship you wouldn't know
i'm sorry what is lucas sinclair's
middle name oh
that's a great question i feel like i
have one
lucas wrist rocket sinclair let's go
with that
according to google people also search
for
these five other people can you guess
who they are
yes i can it's pretty easy
millie gaiton finn
noah sadie nah
joe natalia wow getting
okay i got three i'm surprised millie
and finn isn't there
they also search for these 18 other
people
can you explain why yes okay finn milly
david charlie daker winona
my dad and then miles i was in the new
addition story with him
we worked together before so i
understand that caitlin mclaughlin yes
that's
my younger sister she has she's an
actress as well she can have her own
photo not a picture of me
and then shannon of course shannon yes
we were
worked on stranger things together this
is a google trends graph of your name
searched over time
can you guess what these labeled points
are
oh this is going to be interesting this
is fun stranger things came out in 2016.
i think that's probably why like oh oh
there's a oh caleb oh i didn't know who
this guy was i guess it was just
people were searching like who was this
black kid i don't know 11
20 17. oh
when did season two come out yup yeah
yeah cause it came out on halloween and
if it was in november it was literally
like the day after so
yeah 2019. with season three
yeah that's crazy you see
the spike the difference in the seasons
you see season one
is kind of like lower than season two
and then season three is just
skyrocketed
that's crazy it's cool to actually see
it on like a graph
on rotten tomatoes these are your top
rated movies can you explain your role
in these
sure can concrete cowboy it's my first
starring role in the film it's about a
boy nicole that is sent to live with his
estranged father in philadelphia and his
time down there
he experiences the urban cowboy culture
you see idris elba is on
the poster as well meeting him and
working with him was on a different
level so
it was a great experience i had no idea
about the
urban cowboy life in philadelphia i was
introduced to it
coming onto the film and working in
philly i actually spent a month
training with horses like people think
that you know hopping on a horse
you just get up on you know yeehaw into
the sunset but it's
you know it's different than that you
have to build a bond with the horse you
have to learn
everything about the horse and in that
time the horse is learning everything
about you
it was an experience it was a journey
for sure high flying bird yeah i
was able to have the opportunity to play
a kid that loves basketball darius so i
got to work with um melvin greg shout
out to melvin greg he's doing his thing
in snowfall right now and
the the legend steven soderbergh a great
time working with him
you know just watching him at work it
was a lot of fun
this is what you're known for on imdb
can you explain why lauren ordered svu
yes i played boy and lauren order svu
that was like my first television guest
starring role
super excited it was a lot of fun yeah
as you see it says boy
i'm boy lucas sinclair stranger things
yes i mean between lauren or svu there's
so much stuff i've done
before between that so it was low in
order forever
show me a hero shades of blue and blue
bloods
i've done a few things on television
before but
that's the ones that i guess that stood
out to a lot of people in the new
edition story
i played young ricky bell shout out to
ricky bell the goat
new edition is an 80s r b group that a
lot of my
parents grew up on a lot of people your
parents probably grew up on it it was a
three-part mini-series
i had a lot of fun doing that
there are 3148 images of you on getty
when sorted by oldest this image
from july 1st 2013 comes up first
that is funny it was the theater awards
it was the fifth annual high school
theater awards yes and i think that was
like my first like red carpet event that
i attended my boy caleb is slick with
the white suit
i don't even think it was white i think
it was like a blue
oh man i was just slick i don't know man
that's crazy i look different
when sorting on getty images by most
popular this
is the top result this was season three
of stranger things premiere
this was our biggest premiere was in l.a
santa monica pier and i was in my
pierre moss drip you feeling me yeah i
was just
chilling that day yeah i do remember
that that's interesting that's the top
result that's what's up though
i was like this just that's how i look
like that and as you see there it's kind
of gives me concrete cowboy vibes too i
found out i got it i think like the day
before
and then i remember my stylist daryl he
was like yo we should you know
put on like you know the cowboy kind of
like look and i was like yeah you know
getting character or whatever
so yeah these are your most viewed
videos on youtube
can you guess what they are no i can't
i'm sorry
yeah i would like let's just look at him
i'm not going to try to guess oh
stranger things kevin mclaughlin goes
sneaker shopping with complex yeah so
people a lot of people like that that
that was cool that was smooth that was a
lot of fun i think a lot of people
loved my authenticity
on like my thoughts on sneakers because
i was just saying random stuff like i
just
i compared like yeezys to like the
thanos chin
right now i am trying to like redo my
whole closet and
clean out all the old stuff and bring on
some
new gear uh caleb mclaughlin performs
hello cool j's i'm bad lip sync battle
that was fun i love cool j the goat you
know he hosts
lip sync battle and i feel like i should
pay homage to him and
you know his career he's done so great
in the industry
so i was like you know what i'm gonna do
i'm bad yeah that was a lot of fun
everyone's like whoa you can perform
like yup i can
you didn't know that showed you stranger
things caleb mclaughlin goes undercover
on reddit twitter and youtube wow 1.1
million views
wow a year ago i appreciate everyone you
know checking me out
we collected all the comments on those
three videos
and made this word cloud thanos
i told you that thanos i told you people
loved when i was like
he's funny he's thanos chin thing
stranger thinks fan travis scott oh i
got some travis scott's yeah
you know what's crazy i only wore them
once they're just in my closet because
i'm not even trying to mess them up
they're too
spicy they look too good make loving
i don't know why they mention big love
and that's funny shout out to mclovin
asmr a lot of people say they like my
voice
we tracked down some of the asmr related
comments his voice is so calm and
relaxing to listen
to i appreciate it yeah when i'm
comfortable i have a nice relaxing voice
yeah
thanks he def can do great asmr videos
appreciate it you know i should start
doing that just so i heard that uh
everyone likes my voice that's
interesting i'm wearing my lebrons right
now they're comfortable
i feel good in them i love playing
basketball in them break people's ankles
yeah some of the stuff
hey guys how are you twitter
this was your most liked media post of
2020.
hey guys looking to buy a car for my
birthday any suggestions
from the replies these are the 50 most
recent
recommendations oh smooth everyone's
gonna say a tesla because like that's
the new thing why not get a tesla
i might get in the future but not for
the first car
g that's a good that's a good one too
ferrari expensive lamborghini expensive
again would not do that now in the
future love all these cars
honda civic it's not even on the list
that's crazy we searched instagram for
some of your top posts
can you speak about each of these um
yeah that was me and charlie
he's so funny love charlie we honestly
can't film together in like season three
we had most of our scenes together in
season three we realized we can't work
together
without laughing we will get it done
because we are professional charlie and
i are professional
it was one it was one scene that we were
filming
i was standing behind him and
i think he thought i was laughing but i
was just breathing i was just like this
[Music]
and then all you see is him just
what are you laughing for i'm like i'm
not laughing
but no there's no games on set we don't
laugh what am i talking about we're not
laughing forget about it all right
justin bieber i met him at the nba
all-star weekend in 2018
he was like yo you look familiar i'm
like yeah i'm on um
i'm on a tv show and like stranger
things he's like you're that's you
it's like yo you look totally different
bro you look like a nerd on the show you
look cooler in person i was like thank
you man i appreciate it
this was a lot of fun she was super nice
she
was a comic con she asked me to dance
and i was like sure and she was
dancing with me and stuff so it was cool
it was fun
oh that man that was a lot
i think it was great hope you guys liked
it it was a lot of me today
i'm gonna cleanse from that and look up
other people and stalk other people now
no i'm joking i don't do that